ok ok ok ok ok ok j'ai reçu ça enfin
j'ai plutôt reçu ça plutôt ça qu'il faut
je vous montre ça c'est le nouvel ipad
hier ipad r de cinquième génération
qu'apple a présenté la semaine dernière
dernière c'était très très rapide et
puis je m'amuse avec un j'ai fait plein
de trucs des jeux des six du lightroom
et et puis on va regarder ce que raconte
ipad est alors skype à dire qu'ils
n'arrivent pas tout seul vous savez
c'est une notion d'écosystème c'est
intéressant on a donc un ipad est requis
énormément dans cette boîte mais qui
déjà installé on va venir l'utiliser
avec un apple pencil qu'on va retrouver
juste weiping bien évidemment avec les
magic qui bordent qui n'est pas juste un
clavier mais qui en plus un clavier une
protection qui transforme votre ipad r
en ordinateurs et d'autant plus
aujourd'hui puisque vous avez une puce
m1 à l'intérieur donc on va faire un
tour de style pas d'air on va regarder
quelles sont les différences par rapport
à l'ipad hier de quatrième génération
j'étais bien les bonnes manières à ce
moment je me trompe pas c'est bien ça
par rapport à la quatrième génération y
en a quelques-unes elles sont assez
significatives s'emmène l'ipad r un peu
ailleurs c'est pas mal pas de pro sahara
ça n'a pas l'air il a fait remarquer
plutôt cool line liban
l'ipad r cette année c'est celui là
alors oui je vous le prend je voulais je
vous le sort vous avez le choix entre
acheter juste un air pas de terre c'est
à dire c'est ça n'aille pas devient en
fait c'est un ipad tout simplement et
puis l'ipad r de cette année
rien ne va plus l'ipad r de cette année
il est très similaire à l'ipad hier de
l'année dernière c'est à dire que on a
le même esprit on a le même design on a
vraiment la même chose à regarder et je
vois pas trop la différence si vous
regardez comme ça entre un ipad r de
cette année un ipad r de l'année d'avant
exactement le même design c'est vraiment
la même chose on attache heidi sur le
dessus pour venir déverrouiller
facilement vous avez au niveau du goba
c'est pareil c'est vrai c'est la même
chose aux plats bon les couleurs sont
pas les mêmes nous permet de venir les
différencier parce que sinon c'est
vraiment la même esprit alors il ya des
specs qui sont différentes qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait là j'ai sali mon ipad r donc
voyez c'est c'est la même chose en fait
au niveau du design attention juste au
niveau du design parce qu'en réalité des
différences qui sont vraiment là et
qu'il faut vraiment que l'autre alors
ces différences elles sont pas énormes
mais y en a quelques unes elles sont pas
humains sont quand même significatif
la première c'est la puce on passe d'une
à 14 bionic qu'on avait l'année dernière
et on va vers une puce m1 apple alors là
c'est quand même assez énorme alors
c'était déjà une puce apple la a14
bionique mais là émincés autre chose
vous souvenez vous la est mort quand
elle a été intégrée dans les macbook il
ya quoi ça fait déjà un an et demi un an
et demi c'était une petite révolution à
puce et plus elles ont soutenu une
petite claque à intel en termes de
performances donc on voit arriver une
pucelle nord déjà eu dans l'ipad promet
qu'on la voit arriver dans l'ipad r ça
veut dire que l'ipad r vachement plus
loin termes de performances alors ici
scapa nous annoncent et jusqu'à + 60 %
de performances au niveau du cpu donc au
niveau de la puissance de calcul du
processeur pour avoir un gpu donc côté
graphique qui va être deux fois plus
puissant voilà je vous lis ou fait tout
comme ça et puis voilà ça aille plus
vite en fait c'est l'idée d'une machine
qui va être beaucoup plus vite donc là
c'est le premier point et qu'il faut
vraiment connaître le deuxième point
c'est au niveau de la caméra de celle
fiscaux d'apparat facetime ici chez
apple eh bien vous passez d'une cette
méga pixels qui avait une ouverture à f
2.2 et vous arrivez à 12 mégapixels avec
une ouverture à f 2.4 alors sur le
papier on se dira ok bon oui oui mais
quand même on est d'aller un peu plus
loin au niveau de la vision et puis vous
avez un truc qui est intéressant qui
sont venu rajouter c'est ce qu'ils
appellent ici le cadre centre et que
vous n'aviez pas sur l'ipad r et que
vous retrouvez donc ça c'est pas là j'ai
voulu montrer pour de la visio c'est
vachement cool et puis surtout un autre
point qui est essentiel et qui vient
d'arriver c'est à dire qu'avant vous
aviez de la kadji le savent il ya deux
versions il ya une version purement wii
fit plus une version wii fit plus
cellular c'est à dire que vous pouviez
avoir la 4g il avoue passer de 4 g à 5g
donc ça c'est pareil c'est un bond en
avant qui était vraiment attendu et qui
paraît complètement normal et légitime
et qu'on attendait pour autant est-ce
qu'il faut acheter une version
cellulaire je ne suis pas convaincu ça
dépend vraiment de vos usages on va
regarder s'il ya quelques instants voilà
vous avez les différences la puce la
caméra et la cage des 5 g alors autant
dire que pour moi la 4g cinq jeux c'est
vraiment un truc que j'ai à mettre entre
parenthèse parce que je suis pas du tout
du tout sûr qu'il faille acheter
aujourd'hui une version cellules assure
un ipad r la caméra de celle ci c'est
bien ça va dans le sens de l'histoire et
je vous montrais le bénéfice et on lie
ça c'est super intéressant mais ouvrez
vos bénéfices et le vrai intérêt de cet
ipad r aujourd'hui en 2022 sur la
cinquième génération c'est la puce et
non parce que c'est vraiment ce qui est
extrêmement important une puce et main
ça va quand même vachement plus vite ça
permet d'avoir des ouvertures plus
rapide permet d'avoir plus de puissance
de calcul lorsque vous allez venir
travailler faire du multitâche pense que
vous allez venir faire de la retouche
lorsque j'avais bien faire plein de
choses donc ça ça va vraiment dans ce
sens de l'histoire et c'est super
intéressant ce qui permet de transformer
cet ipad r encore plus en un ordinateur
et ça c'est très chouette alors pour le
transforme en ordinateur on fait quoi on
utilise ça et ça c'est quoi c'est le
magic qui borde le magic qui bordent il
a été présenté avec l'ipad pro il ya
deux ans je crois déjà et ce magic qui
bordent il est super bien parce que vous
prenez regardez vous le prenez comme ça
et vous venez poser votre ipad r
directement dedans et qu'est ce qui se
passe dans votre ipad r devient un
ordinateur et ça c'est très chouette à
regarder tahir que lorsque c'est pas
tout nouveau ce que je vous montre ainsi
un truc qu'on connaissait déjà vous avez
effectivement et bien le côté de votre
magic qui borde sa broche en plus une
petite prise usb ces lieux de ces trois
points c'est la deuxième génération qui
vous permet d'aller jusqu'à 10 gigabits
par seconde alors bon pas celui là on
est celui que vous avez lancée du trois
pauses ok et alors qu'est ce qui vous
permet de faire c'est usb ces trois
points en or de ce que permet de le
recharger ça c'est vachement bien
d'autant plus que vous avez un blog de
charges incluent de 20 watts vous savez
ils se mettent plus haut niveau des
smartphones et au niveau notamment des
iphone parce qu'on considère que vous
avez déjà un bloc de charges puisque
vous avez déjà un smartphone d'avant ici
apple se dit peut-être les gens
n'avaient pas déjà un ipad donc il faut
qu'on leur mettre un bloc de charge donc
vous avez votre blog de charge de 20
watts inclus et donc ça c'est plutôt
bien alors on peut le recharger bien
évidemment ça c'est pratique vous pouvez
également venir brancher un disque dur
externe et venir faire de la sauvegarde
ok vous pouvez venir branché également
avec un adaptateur et bien ça me permet
d'avoir du vga de la hdmi du dvi
également un display port dont vous
pouvez venir branché on doit utiliser un
écran un moniteur externe que vous allez
brancher directement ici en usb c'est
donc ça c'est intéressant également donc
on voit ici que cet acte pâle avec la
puissance et la performance que vient
lui rajouter là puissamment et bien
devient de plus en plus à un petit
ordinateur et ça c'est vachement cool
alors je passe ici vous le savez mais en
règle générale parce qu'on vient de
gagner en performance lorsqu'on vient
gagner avec des puces beaucoup plus
puissante on vient également gagné un
petit peu en autonomie alors pour autant
apple et si nous annonce exactement la
même chose que ce qu'on avait l'année
dernière lors il est évident que cette
puce vient apporter en regain de
performance mais va peut-être venir
consommer un peu davantage au niveau de
la batterie pour autant c'est la même
batterie on nous annonce exactement la
même autonomie donc bon rien de bien
différent ici entre un ipad de cinquième
génération dans les pattes de quatrième
génération le format je vous dis c'est
exactement le même on a atteint les 10
sur le dessus mais ça je voulais
également dit et puis y'a un truc
intéressant cette caméra alors regardez
je vais vous mettre les deux ipad côte à
côte pour vous puissiez vous rendre
compte
ça c'est le nouvel ipad ça c'est
l'ancien regarder le nouveau je bouge il
me suis alors que l'ancien il m'a
complètement perdus chez plus de dents
voyez je vais sur le haut et bien le
nouveau leurs imams et dans la limite de
l'ancienne a perdu jeune bai cela le
nouveau il m'a encore je me baisse le
nouveau mât l'ancien m'a plu du tout
vous voyez c'est pareil je vais de
l'autre côté le nouveau mât et l'ancien
m'a plu voyait l'ancien le nouveau donc
il ya une vraie différence est là je
reviens sur mes au centre est là tous
les deux m'ont donc la hausse que je me
rapproche encore en ce pays perd évident
que la caméra comme ça de vous montrer
mais je me rapproche encore donc là immo
je me décale je me décale jeune des
quatre jeunes décale yang comment son
père vers des élus suivent de façon
dynamique et intelligente donc ça c'est
vachement bien il ya vraiment un vrai
bénéfice là voyage monte l'uimm à l'huma
perdu la tête je ne baisse donc ça c'est
la caméra centrer et la caméra centre et
il ya un bénéficiant des périodes 1 qui
perd pas donc alors l'idée c'est pas
quand on fait des visio d'aller se
balader comme ça mais pour autant ça
marche vraiment bien c'est un truc qui
marche vachement bien et qui est super
super super intéressant et sur lequel
apple a vraiment vraiment bien bossé
l'idée c'est pas de se dire ok je vais
bouger faire n'importe quoi me balader à
droite à gauche non c'est juste d'être
tranquille dans sa tête c'est dire si je
bouge un peu j'ai la caméra qu'ils me
sucent apporte plus de fluidité pour les
gens avec qui vous allez venir converser
lorsque vous allez faire une vision qui
soit pour travailler ou de la famille et
compagnie pascal vachement mieux c'est
quand même vachement plus qualitatif
donc ça c'est vachement cool si vous
avez un nouveau processeur signal
d'image qui s'appelle l' esprit qui va
tout nouveau tram train d'aller plus
loin d'avoir une plus grosse capacité
calcul grâce à la puce et main on a
toujours le smart hdr qui est là et puis
à l'arrière c'est exactement la même
caméra que vous avez c'est une 12
mégapixels ouvre à f 1.8 c'est
exactement la même chose ça change pas
la règle l'écran ne change pas c'est
toujours la même chose c'est à dire que
c'est un écran les tuileries tina c'est
diagonale de 10,1 9 pouces full hd +
2360 pas mille 640 pixels à 264 pixels
par pouce et avec une luminosité à 500
dit la même chose ça bouge pas de l'un à
l'autre c'est d'une dalle ips ici des
haut-parleurs stéréo de ce côté là et de
ce côté là donc vous allez avoir une
expérience de stéréoscopie lorsque vous
allez le tenir comme ça en mode paysage
mais pas un mode portrait parce que le
son vient de renvoyer dent et d'en bas
donc ça fonctionnera pas on l'a toujours
du bluetooth 5.0 donc ça ça change pas
non plus rien ce qui change c'est le
tarif une petite évolution au niveau du
tarif regarder je vais vous le montrez
la pop là vous avez donc 2 confie vous
avez soit une version wifi soit une
version qu'on va appeler cellular donc
c'est la 5g en fait un + wifi d'un il ya
du wi fi de tous les côtés et vous avez
deux confie soit une config en 64 giga
de stockage soit une config en 256 giga
de stockage c'était la même chose alors
vous êtes aujourd'hui ici à gérer tarifs
sur le côté c'est à 699 euros sur la
version wifi 64 sur la version 256 7 à
869 euros hockey au monde quand même
vous êtes sans la version ici la
cellular 64 à 869 euros donc ces mêmes
prix que celui là et là vous êtes à 1039
euros et il faut savoir que vous avez
effectivement une différence parce que
les prix ont augmenté par rapport à ce
qu'on avait sur la quatrième génération
pour la quatrième génération vous étiez
à 669 euros c'est à dire 30 euros - là
vous étiez à 839 euros donc 39
euros/mois et là vous étiez à
809 euros dont 60 euros de moins et là
vous étiez à
979 euros dont 60 euros de moins donc là
sur la version wifi on appris ici plus
30 euros de la génération d'avant cette
génération là et sur la version
cellulaire + wifi vous avez pris plus 60
euros ça c'est dû au fait d'avoir ici la
5g et la puce m et ici c'est dû au fait
d'avoir la pucelle moi donc c'est plus
ça demain ils vous coûte 30 euros de
plus par rapport aux tarifs 9 de la
génération précédente et la 5g plus la
puce à main et bien ça fait trente euros
chacun et donc on pourrait imaginer qu
effectivement la 5g c'est plus 30 euros
et on pourrait imaginer que la puce m 1
c'est plus 30 euros ce qui justifie ces
60 euros et si je vous dis juste la puce
et moins on va dire ben ça justifie ces
fameux plus 30 euros ou non ça ça me
paraît complètement normal et pas du
tout problématique vu qu'on a un vrai
gars quand même entre la 14 bionic et la
puce est mince à markhamat achement plus
vite et on l'a vu parce que c'est plus
simple on peut le retrouver aussi bien
sur un ipad trop son ipad est
aujourd'hui sur la cinquième génération
que sur un macbook air par exemple donc
bon c'est pas rien quoi franchement
c'est un vrai gain de performance tout
en sachant que si vous voulez en plus un
apple pencil que j'ai mis juste là il
est compatible avec l'apple pensi de
deuxième génération alors il faut me
rajouter un peu plus au niveau du tarif
n'est plus le cas si si l'apple pencil
de deuxième génération il coûte 135
euros qui n'est globalement pas rien et
le magic qui bordent que je vous ai
présenté la saxe un magic qui bordent
effet pour en ehpad pro 11 pouces ou
pour un ipad r 19 pouces et bien on est
à 3 139 euros je trouve que ce
accessoires il est vachement bien mais
il est horriblement cher 339 euros alors
moyens tu que je vous recommande je vous
conseille réellement ici au niveau de
votre ipad r au niveau de ses confidents
regarder pour moi la config 64 gigas est
beaucoup trop petit parce que même si on
stocke aujourd'hui dans le club et que
on se dit qu'il ya pas de soucis que le
cloud c'est bien c'est quand même
vachement petit 64 giga vous avec limité
si comme moi regardez vous avez des
pages et des pages et des pages avec
pleins d'applications tous les côtés
vous vous dites n'encaisse que j'ai fait
à 64 giga ça marche pas donc vous prenez
à minima cette version étrangers peuple
à 256 à 869 euros et ça ça fonctionne
est-ce que je vous conseille pour autant
de venir prendre une version cellular 5g
puce wifi pour moi non sauf si vous êtes
je sais pas moi c'est des besoins d'être
tout le temps en extérieur qu elles vous
font réellement une connexion d j'ai à
votre ipad si vous faites un partage de
connexion de votre iphone à votre ipad
et ça marchera voulez vous l'avez
cellulaire donc pour moi ça non non non
je ne conseille pas sauf qu'à réellement
précis mais sinon je vous conseille
réellement devenir prendre la version
wifi la version 256 et la version à 669
euros alors si vous prenez ça
669 +135 parce que l'apple peine si
c'est quand même vachement bien plus 339
va regarder vous arrivez quand même à
1340 3 euros et ça c'est quand même un
très gros tarifs donc c'est une tablette
mais c'est une tablette avec un procès
sans ordinateur avec une expérience
d'ordinateurs qui vous sert de cover qui
vous sert de clavier qui vous donne une
deuxième prise usb sait et c'est une
super machine que vous pouvez prendre
poser pour regarder des films des séries
c'est le grand minimum qu'on attendrait
d'une machine comme ça et sur lequel
vous allez avoir un max de performance
pour venir toucher ce que vous voulez
faire du lightroom si vous voulez
regarder je vais vous montrer ce que je
suis un mec qui lightroom un peu on peut
venir envoyer touché très rapidement
dans les troubles ça réagit vraiment
vraiment bien ça fonctionne à plein si
on a envie de s'amuser un petit peu
poussé un petit peu ici ça donc on peut
vraiment venir à venir bosser
extrêmement facilement et pour moi il
n'y a pas de y'a pas de souci là-dessus
voyez des réductions de coûts et donc il
ya un truc qui marche quoi il y en a une
machine qui est extrêmement réactive à
la main pour venir jouer à des jeux
extrêmement facilement alors je vous ai
pris si un petit final fantasy pourquoi
parce que quand je veux marquer final
fantasy ça me rappel final fantasy 7
auquel je jouais quand j'étais ado et
c'est un jeu au sol quelle j'ai passé
tellement de temps que voilà j'ai
vraiment vraiment adoré donc là c'est
pareil à de la même manière et y est
c'est très fluide ça m'a vachement bien
pour toutes les expériences de gaming
vous n'avez absolument aucun problème
ici pour venir jouer à du final fantasy
à tout ce que vous voulez ça ira
parfaitement bien ça pour avoir une
machine que j'aime beaucoup que j'ai
beaucoup plus utiliser l'ipad r de
quatrième génération j'utilise allait
quasiment tous les jours beaucoup pour
ie divertissement mais on peut utiliser
pour beaucoup d'autres choses et ce qui
est intéressant avec skype a des airs de
cinquième génération deux choses la
première c'est que ça le ramène en
termes de performances au niveau de
l'ipad trop sortie actuellement le
dernier donc sorti l'année dernière mais
ça montre quoi ça montre que cette année
on va voir arriver à nay pas de prix
encore plus puissant avec une autre puce
avec une mêmes pros et d'un homme
maxence et rien parce qu'il va falloir
qu'ils sont quand même au dessus l'ipad
pro par rapport à l'ipad r donc quand il
se passe si vous voulez acheter un ipad
la quatrième génération reste corne est
très bonne il n'y a pas de soucis vous
pourrez trouver moins cher aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse c est pas
jude un lien en bas dans la description
mais l'ipad la de cinquième génération
comme il est là il est vachement bien
pour venir bosser pour venir jouer pour
gagner des films des séries c'est un
format qui est très cool de 19 pouces
c'est un format qui est vachement bien
parce que pas trop haut parce que facile
à emmener avec soi et une fois que vous
avez mis à tous les accessoires derrière
ça va vous coûter cher je vous dis on
est à 1300 euros dans la config que je
vous recommande est ici mais c'est vrai
qu'on a une très jolie machine voilà
c'est ce que ça va vous raconter
aujourd'hui son cet ipad r 2022 on verra
arriver je pense d'ici très peu de temps
n'avez pas de projet ou encore plus
booster encore plus musclé pour ça c'est
une autre histoire dont vous invite dès
maintenant à venir vous abonner s'est
pas déjà le cas cliquez sur le petit
bouton rouge si les rouches elle vous
n'êtes pas abonné et dès que vous vous
êtes abonné d'ailleurs si vous êtes déjà
abonné penser à actionner la cloche pour
authentifier avec une prochaine vidéo
arrivera et ça c'est vachement cool
allez je vous embrasse prenez soin de
vous on se trouve très rapidement pour
continuer à parler d'apple évidemment
parce que l'on parle de l'ipad est remis
a également un iphone est ce qui a été
présenté une troisième génération de
l'iphone est ce donc ça on en parlera
avec également l'arrivée de la 5g sur
l'iphone et celui on va voir si les
promesses sont tenues et qu'est ce qu'il
raconte un peu et puis on prend là je
pense aussi très prochainement de l'ipad
pro qui saurait tarder à arriver parce
qu'il avait toujours là dans le monde au
mois de mars pour lé soin de vous et vos
bisou à bientôt le cha
[Musique]